[Music]
a hero is remembered shuri suits up and
Queen remonda slays in her Regal attire
these are the moments in Black Panther
wakanda forever you'll be pausing at
home
okay so this is cheating but practically
every moment Angela Bassett is on screen
as Queen ramonda is worthy of a pause
Basset to the stunningly beautiful Elder
States woman of wakanda forever is a
believably Regal presence who keeps it
real on the throne and in the halls of
the United Nations but it's the
combination of bassett's poise and the
impossibly gorgeous costumes that Ruth e
Carter designed for the character that
makes every frame of Queen raimonda a
work of art all of Carter's costumes are
top-notch but romonda gets the best
clothes and it's not even close each one
is a statement piece and that statement
is I'm the most important person in the
room
further attempts on our resources will
be considered an act of aggression
each outfit is precisely detailed
sumptuously textured and unique but with
motifs and patterns that run throughout
her whole lookbook her dresses are
usually made of shiny billowing Fabrics
adorned with overlays of intricate metal
work pieces they reference wakanda's
traditions and its scientific
advancements they move well they
photograph well and they suit the
character's elevated stature
speaking of the United Nations two of
the Dora melange's best moments happen
before and after Queen ramonda's
testimony French covert operatives are
attempting to steal and study vibranium
while the nation itself is calling for
stricter oversight measures against
wakanda on the world stage but the door
milaje have a woman on the inside and
several more fully armored women on the
outside as it turns out Okoye and her
Warriors make their slow motion
uberconfident entrance as aneka drops
her undercover Persona and joins the
fight that scene speaks to wakanda's own
intelligence capabilities and it
features some of the most dynamic action
we've seen the door milage engage in so
far a second door milagee scene that
bookends the United Nations hearing is
the international Affairs equivalent of
a mic drop just as France and the U.S
are arguing against wakanda's right to
possess and control vibranium without
oversight Okoye and her Squad burst
through the Hall's doors with the French
special ops subdued and in their custody
the wakandans have successfully
demonstrated the rest of the world's
hypocrisy when it comes to weapons of
mass destruction and their Tiny But
powerful nation and they looked cool
doing it the door melange standing
righteously over the cowering French and
their fatigues makes for one heck of a
plot development and one heck of a cool
shot
when Nakia rescues shuri and Riri
Williams at the behest of Queen Ramona
she inadvertently sets off a war between
wakanda and talocon but before Namor and
his people flood the streets there's
time for Riri to take in her
surroundings the MIT student and Super
Genius is not only familiar with the
secretive African nation but she
recognizes princess shuri at first
glance and is obviously a fan of her
work why wouldn't she be she's young
black and talented as she points out
which is less of a calling card in
wakanda than it is in Boston it's fun to
watch the tech and Avengers obsessed
Riri realize she's been absconded to
what would basically be her Mecca we see
the inside of wakanda's most sacred
places including its research facilities
from her perspective as we've come to
expect from a Black Panther movie these
sets are expertly imagined and crafted
but in one stately room in particular
there's an extra layer of meaning the
door milage stands guard among five
columns all lit from within each column
is decorated with wakandan letters
stacked vertically translated to English
as a fan on Twitter observed these
columns appear to read in power t'challa
our hero and honor forever
Riri might have been in awe of wakanda
but at least she was aware it existed
shuri had no idea there was an entire
civilization hundreds of feet below the
surface of the ocean rich with its own
vibranium deposits in a scene that's
short to draw comparisons to Avatar the
way of water Neymar outfits shuri with a
diving suit and takes her to his home of
telecon the wakandan princess's reverse
Little Mermaid situation benefits from
the palpable tension and Chemistry
Between shuri and Namor but it's also
made more magical by the way the
underwater city slowly reveals itself at
first shuri can only make out faint
light in the distance through the water
gradually her eyes begin to focus on the
kingdom and its people shuri's astounded
by what Neymar has been able to create
over the centuries telecon which has its
own vibranium-powered sun is a paradise
and refuge for Neymar's people who have
already been driven from their territory
at least once the highlight of this
scene is the moment Neymar tells shuri
she's the first person from the surface
to ever see this otherwise undiscovered
watery dream world just as the beautiful
picture of talocon comes into Focus
the prologue opening credits and First
Act of wakanda forever all deal with the
death of t'challa and R as a result
moving but Melancholy but the mood
changes when a cia-led research team is
ambushed on the deck of their massive
base vessel the set piece plays out like
a dark water horror movie and the
audience knows something is amiss before
the characters do Panic sets in when one
of the divers goes missing a flashlight
shines upon his severed frayed cable
seconds later a hunky blue humanoid
bursts out of the water and onto the
deck without warning this isn't neymore
it's a Tuma one of his chief adversaries
in the comics in wakanda Forever he's
used as a brutish underling it's an
interesting choice to lead with the Tuma
and save Neymar's reveal and it's
probably the right one Namor who's more
of an Aztec god king than Marvel Comics
traditional Submariner gets more build
up plus a more mythical and memorable
debut shortly thereafter when he emerges
from the water's edge with a conch shell
to negotiate with queen ramonda and
shuri but the sketchy CIA mission
gonorai is the film's first dose of
adrenaline and nothing will make you
jump in a helicopter and call for backup
like the sight of the shredded teleconil
coming after you Spears akimbo
almost every MCU film comes standard
with a car chase black panther had one
of the best in Innovative race through
the streets of Busan during what shuri
drives Alexis remotely as a suited up
t'challa leaps and scrapes between
vehicles and the road
the forever's version which takes place
in Boston isn't quite as stylish or
thrilling though it's still a
well-staged bit of spectacle when the
feds show up at riri's friend's garage
where she keeps her research her
prototypes and her classic car the 19
year old mit student has no choice but
to flee with shuri and Okoye Okoye takes
the car sure he hops onto a motorcycle
and re-reclimes into what we can assume
is the Mark 1 of her Iron Heart suit
made of Auto Parts the chase itself
isn't very long but it Harkens back to
daring stunts from the mcu's past
including the one in black panther early
Ironman flight sequences and t'challa's
pursuit of Bucky in Captain America
Civil War but there's something that
makes this chase scene special the Black
Panther movies rightly get attention for
their majority black casts but they
don't get enough credit for their
majority female characters when the
frame freezes on shuri Okoye and Riri
and their kinetic poses we realize how
rare it is and how awesome it looks to
see three capable women in the middle of
the action
the positive reception to Michael B
Jordan's Eric killmonger proved that MCU
audiences like to like their villains
wakanda forever continues that Trend
with Namor and anti-hero with an updated
backstory that almost makes us want to
root for him even when he's killing off
main characters we also love the film
tells us his origin story and flashback
while he narrates the curious and tragic
tale to shuri his mother's people
ingested their native vibranium enhanced
plants but instead of giving them the
strength of the panther it sent them
into the sea neymor who was still in his
mother's womb was born a mutant as a
result though their civilization began
to thrive underwater his mother longed
for the normal human life that the
Invaders and the herb had taken away
from her upon her death Neymar promises
he'll bury her in the land she loved but
when it's time for him to keep that
promise The Grieving child finds that
conquerors have ravaged her country and
will Slaughter every indigenous person
blue or otherwise in sight he Taps into
his mutant superpowers to set fire to
their colony and quell their attack this
earns him his people's adoration and the
name kukul Khan or The Feathered Serpent
God but the colonizers view him as a
monster and call him a boy without love
no Amor which begets his name neymore my
enemies call me no more he takes both
names as a source of Pride The Haunting
twin shots in which the Spanish
oppressors scatter amidst the Flames as
a vengeful young Neymar watches
everything burn establish the mcu's
latest complex character as equally
sympathetic and scary
fans of Eric killmonger hoped the
character might make an appearance in
wakanda forever but as the film hurtled
towards its conclusion with only a stray
mention of t'challa's dead cousin and
foe those hopes began to fade then just
when audience is least expected it
killmonger shows up in one of the mcu's
most thoughtful and effective cameos to
date after shuri produces a 99 effective
lab-created heart-shaped herb she tests
it on herself instead of a traditional
ceremony the princess just wants someone
to monitor her vitals with kamoyo beads
wakanda forever is able to pull off the
surprise because shuri doesn't expect to
see anyone when she reaches the
ancestral plane if she reaches it at all
it's heavily implied she's a
non-believer in the afterlife which is
why she's struggling so much with
t'challa's death She's overwhelmed and
disoriented when she comes to and sees
that the spiritual realm is real then
she sees the back of her family's Throne
she calls out for her mother father and
brother but instead she finds the last
person she expected to meet in some
version of Heaven killmonger they have a
brutally honest conversation that
becomes a turning point for shuri it's
one of the standout scenes in the movie
but the moment we realize who's on the
throne is what we'll remember
Marvel movies are of course superhero
stories and comic book adaptations
choreographed fights quippy dialogue
Easter eggs and CGI explosions are part
of the deal to be sure the excess and
the exhilaration are part of what make
the genre so popular but with black
panther wakanda forever the cast and
crew were given the opportunity to do
something more restrained and
contemplative especially in the first
and last scenes t'challa dies not at the
hands of the enemy or in some convoluted
plot twist but from illness to mourn
honor and celebrate this step in the
king's Journey the filmmakers have
orchestrated a moving and magnificent
wakandan funeral worthy of not just the
character but also Chadwick Boseman the
actor who first brought him to the big
screen every aspect the attire the music
the joyous dancing the somber
preparation of the casket is perfectly
rendered but one of the most emotional
images of this or any Marvel movie is
the moment the camera pulls wide to show
the entire nation of wakanda dressed in
white and paying its respects
wakanda forever ends as shuri Burns her
funeral Garb to symbolize that she's
processed t'challa's death as the fibers
go up in Flames she closes her eyes and
remembers her brother as we remember him
in a series of his greatest moments from
the MCU the most indelible of these are
the times t'chella stands at the
Vanguard of his forces be they wakandans
or The Avengers assembled and Crosses
his arms over his chest to Proclaim
wakanda forever
forever
[Music]
it's only fitting that shuri the New
Black Panther should get a Moment Like
This of her own her chance comes as one
might expect when she's about to lead
her Army into battle against Neymar and
the telekinil
it's not the first time we see shuri in
her version of the vibranium reinforced
supersuit that happens when she repels
down into umbaku's mountain lair and
stands before the gathered refugees to
announce that since she's been able to
replicate the heart-shaped herb wakanda
has its protector again her people look
on with astonishment and renewed hope
which lets the viewers get a good long
look at shuri's unique black panther
costume
foreign
[Music]